[Música]
bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa este es el programa en el que
hacemos un repaso por las noticias más
destacadas de la pandemia en nuestro
continente yo soy lacalle y estoy
en reemplazo de santiago lópez quien
está en una asignación de trabajo veamos
qué temas tendremos hoy
hablaremos de qué está pasando en
ucrania en cuanto a la crisis sanitaria
y como la guerra también impacta el
manejo de la pandemia y es que por un
lado la oms se estima que los contagios
pueden incrementar en ese país mientras
que una de las sanciones contra rusia
afectó al fondo que comercializa la
vacuna sputnik ven este fármaco se
distribuye en casi una decena de
naciones latinoamericanas
en esta emisión iremos a eeuu los
centros para el control y la prevención
de enfermedades actualizaron los
lineamientos para tratar la pandemia
ahora las autoridades relajaron el uso
de mascarillas en la mayoría de los
lugares del país además en la ciudad de
nueva york ya no será necesario mostrar
la prueba de vacunación para poder
entrar a los negocios y también
miraremos una historia en bolivia donde
muchos han utilizado la sabiduría
ancestral para tratar los síntomas del
cob y 19 una de las maneras han sido las
infusiones de plantas como el eucalipto
o el mãtico comencemos entonces hablando
de uno de los impactos de la invasión
ordenada por moscú contra ucrania
tiene que ver con las vacunas es que el
fondo encargado de comercializar el
biológico ruso sputnik fue sancionado
mientras que el estado alemán de bavaria
paralizó la producción del fármaco
contra el kobe 19 además la onu indica
que se han realizado pocas pruebas pcr
en los últimos días en ucrania a causa
de la guerra lo que apunta a la
posibilidad de que haya una importante
transmisión de la enfermedad sin
detectar en este territorio arianna
villacorta tiene la historia
el presidente ruso vladimir putin hizo
un anuncio importante
la producción de sputnik ve ya se ha
puesto en marcha en argentina en chino a
pesar de que no ha sido aprobada por la
agencia europea de medicamentos la
vacuna rusa sputnik ve contra el coi 19
se administra en 48 países del mundo
entre ellos perú méxico argentina
venezuela bolivia panamá honduras
paraguay y guatemala según estatista una
empresa alemana especializada en datos
de mercado y consumo sin embargo su uso
podría disminuir ya que el fondo de
inversión directa de rusia que se
encarga de comercializar este fármaco se
está viendo perjudicado por las
sanciones que estados unidos y reino
unido han impuesto debido a la invasión
rusa ucrania mientras que el estado de
baviera en alemania informó que
bloqueara la producción de estimulante
que se esperaba que produjera entre 8 y
10 millones de vacunas al mes una
situación que preocupa la organización
mundial de la salud que considera
urgente establecer un corredor en
ucrania para garantizar que los
trabajadores humanitarios y los
suministros tengan un acceso seguro y
continuo para llegar a las personas
necesitadas de la oms está muy
preocupada por el desarrollo de la
emergencia humanitaria en ucrania y
craig wilson y también nos preocupan
profundamente los informes sobre ataques
a instalaciones y trabajadores
sanitarios workers de shanxi y hay que
respetar y proteger la inviolabilidad y
neutralidad de atención sanitaria
incluidos los trabajadores sanitarios
los pacientes los suministros el
transporte y las instalaciones así como
el derecho a un acceso seguro a la
atención picture and project lado ms
también alertó que es muy probable que
se produzca un aumento significativo de
contagios en ucrania y en los países
vecinos que ya acogen a más de un millón
de refugiados que han salido de
territorio ucraniano en la última semana
huyendo de los enfrentamientos
cifras proporcionadas por la acnur
además prevé que el escasez de oxígeno
tendrá un impacto en la capacidad de
tratar a pacientes con kobe 19 y otras
condiciones ya que al menos tres de las
principales plantas de oxígeno en
ucrania han cerrado debido a la
intervención militar rusa ucrania es uno
de los países europeos con la menor tasa
de vacunación
el 34 5% de su población total que
cuenta con más de 44 millones de
habitantes se ha inoculado con el
esquema completo
y es que esta situación no es muy común
tener una pandemia y luego una guerra
para entender cómo se está manejando la
crisis sanitaria en ucrania conectamos a
esta hora con daniel lópez acuña él es
epidemiólogo y ex director de acción
sanitaria en situaciones de crisis de la
organización mundial de la salud señor
lópez bienvenido a france 24 y es un
placer tenerlo con nosotros comencemos
hablando entonces de cómo es la crisis
sanitaria en medio del conflicto y cómo
manejarla
bueno en todo conflicto armado tenemos
un impacto humanitario
notable y una crisis que afecta al
sistema de salud una crisis sanitaria
que naturalmente se ve aún más
incrementada cuando esto ocurre en el
medio de una dinámica pandémica como la
que tenemos de kobe decimal hay que
entender que el impacto se da en la
disrupción que se causa en el sistema de
salud y en la prestación de servicios en
el acceso de medicamentos insumos como
el oxígeno vacunas para la población en
la posibilidad de acceder a la población
para prestarle los servicios incluir a
la vacuna o incluidas las pruebas
diagnósticas y tenemos una combinación
entonces de
disrupción generada por la pandemia a la
que se le agrega la enorme disrupción y
destrucción y ataque de instalaciones
sanitarias generada por la guerra por
esta invasión que está experimentando
ucrania por parte de la federación rusa
y usted nos habla de la disrupción
actual pero cuál era la situación en
cuanto a los contagios y a la vacunación
en ucrania y en los países vecinos antes
de que comenzara la guerra
si teníamos una situación mala en
términos de gestión o control de la
pandemia en ucrania desde antes de la
invasión recordemos que además ucrania
es un país en donde hay un conflicto
abierto en el este de ucrania entre
rusia y ucrania en la zona del donbass
desde el año 2014 que ha requerido
acción humanitaria y multitud de
agencias de las naciones unidas la cruz
roja' ongs han estado trabajando en este
territorio para tratar de que la gente
ahí por acceso a servicios básicos
sanitarios y de otra y pero la situación
en términos de la pandemia es que cayera
uno de los es uno de los países que
tenía la tasa de vacunación más baja en
todo el continente europeo no no
llegábamos siquiera un 35 por ciento de
la población vacunada con pauta completa
esto ya genera una gran vulnerabilidad
del 65 por ciento de la población ante
mis odios severos y episodios que pueden
buscar en una en un fallecimiento
además de tener baja vacunación un clan
ya tenía una muy alta incidencia que
llegaba a cifras de 3000 o más por
100.000 habitantes una importante
presión asistencial un número
considerable de hospitalizaciones y todo
esto nos llevamos a una situación muy
crítica
previa a la instalación de la invasión y
a la disrupción que genera el conflicto
bélico yo creo que estamos ante una
situación que es muy explosiva desde el
punto de vista pandémico pero que
naturalmente tiene efectos en otros
ámbitos sanitarios recordemos que en una
guerra se deja de poder vacunar de a
poder atender en las maternidades a las
mujeres embarazadas muchas de ellas
están siendo atendidas en los refugios
antiaéreos o en o en el éxodo que están
teniendo se plantean los desafíos de
cómo es asegurar la continuidad de
medidas como la vacunación incluso
normal
a los niños y adolescentes que están
teniendo que salir del país y que están
refugiándose en distintos países vecinos
de la unión europea entonces la
disrupción es es doble y recordemos que
la crisis humanitaria de ucrania implica
problemas para la gente que sé que está
en ucrania que está en el interior del
país por problemas de movilidad de
destrucción de disfuncionalidad del
sistema sanitario y los problemas
asociados a la salud que tiene que ver
con ese millón de personas que ya ha
salido de ucrania hacia los países
vecinos por fortuna la unión europea ha
viabilizado el que puedan pasar sin
trabas burocráticas como si las hubo
para los migrantes de países musulmanes
en el 2015 y 2016 pero ahora vendrá todo
el tema de la acogida el techo de la
alimentación y los servicios sanitarios
que tendrán que ofrecerse a toda esta
población migrante que naturalmente no
es una migración temporal
si no es la primera vez que una guerra
coincide con un brote ya habíamos visto
algo similar cuando rusia se anexó a
crimea en 2014 con el repunte de
sarampión que hubo que otros casos
similares hay y como se han manejado
bueno siempre en la guerra o los
conflictos
intensifican o incrementan los problemas
de carácter epidémico que podemos tener
hay multitud de ejemplos a lo largo la
historia de
agravamiento de la situación de
epidemias de cólera de epidemias de
meningitis de reducción de la cobertura
vacunal para el sarampión o la polio que
nos llevan a una regresión en términos
sanitarios por ejemplo todo el conflicto
en afganistán a lo largo de los años
generó una imposibilidad de acceder a
poblaciones aisladas para la vacunación
completa de la polio de los países que
más resistentes han sido hasta el final
para la eliminación de la polio han sido
países como pakistán o afganistán en las
zonas más alejadas y en las zonas de
conflicto que han llevado por ejemplo a
tener que establecer corredores
humanitarios
negociados entre en el pasado los
gobiernos existentes con los talibanes y
en la actualidad un diálogo con los
talibanes para poder acceder
servicios yo creo que esto nos debe
demostrar la urgencia que tiene el
establecimiento de corredores
humanitarios de corredores sanitarios
para poder asegurar el suministro de
insumos básicos la prestación de
servicios y el detener el impacto que
esto pueda tener en las vidas de las
personas si miramos a futuro usted ya
nos explicaba un poco las implicaciones
que la guerra puede tener en la salud
pública concretamente frente a la
pandemia del cobi 19 que podría pasar
bueno el escenario más probable con la
pandemia del 19 en ucrania es que se
intensifique la transmisión en estos
momentos no hay manera de tener
controles adecuados no hay manera
siquiera de medir el número de casos en
número de hospitalizaciones el número de
vacunas que se ponen o el número de
defunciones si uno ve las cifras de our
world in data
que lleva la universidad de johns
hopkins sobre la epidemia de la pandemia
de kobe décima vez uno ve que se han
caído los datos para ucrania en la
última semana a partir de la invasión y
eso implica un reflejo eso refleja
claramente el que hay límites muy
grandes para poder contener lo que ya de
por sí era una pandemia no controlada en
el caso del doctor daniel lópez gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa y continuamos
haciendo un recorrido en algunos países
del caribe para mirar cómo ha avanzado
precisamente el kobe 19 desde sus
inicios las siguientes estadísticas son
del conteo que lleva la universidad
johns atkins en bahamas se han
confirmado más de 33 mil casos de covite
19 de esos se han reportado 771 muertos
en haití y los contagios ascienden a
30.000 y los fallecimientos son 820
aunque allí hay una falta generalizada
de pruebas y las cifras oficiales pueden
ser más bajas frente a la realidad en
jamaica ha habido más de 128 mil
diagnósticos positivos y los decesos
superan los 2800
ahora vamos a eeuu donde los casos de
coronavirus han caído drásticamente
desde que alcanzaron su pico en enero
esto impulsó a las autoridades
sanitarias a cambiar las guías para
tratar la pandemia a mensah la tiene la
información desde nueva york mama
bienvenida y explícanos en qué consisten
los cambios de las guías
si los centros para el control y
prevención de enfermedades acaban de
actualizar sus recomendaciones para
luchar contra la pandemia y a partir de
ahora eeuu comienza una nueva etapa sin
mascarillas esto que significa pues bien
según los estudios de las autoridades
sanitarias el 90 por ciento de los
estadounidenses viven en zonas donde el
riesgo de contagio por kobe 19 es bajo o
medio por lo que no sería necesario
recomiendan estas autoridades sanitarias
el uso de la mascarilla ojo porque
también advierten que todavía hay un 37
por ciento de zonas en el país donde
este riesgo continúa siendo alto este
riesgo de contagio y allí sí que
recomiendan utilizar la mascarilla es
por ejemplo puerto rico- o jaguar a qué
se debe este cambio de recomendaciones
primero porque consideran que ya hemos
superado la ola de contagios que produjo
la variante omicron y segundo porque ha
habido un cambio en los factores a tener
en cuenta a la hora de tomar decisiones
ya no se va a prestar tanta atención al
número de contagios se va a seguir
haciendo pero no va a ser una métrica
primor y fundamental si no se va a
prestar más atención a cómo están los
hospitales y en función de estos
parámetros esta es la conclusión a la
que han llegado que se puede levantar y
relajar el uso de la mascarilla en eeuu
además de la recomendación de eliminar
la mascarilla la ciudad de nueva york
está tomando otras decisiones cuéntanos
en qué consisten estas nuevas medidas
si esta semana el estado de nueva york
dice adiós en la mascarilla en los
lugares públicos cerrados eso sí las
empresas tendrán el derecho a decidir si
quieren que sus trabajadores y que sus
clientes sigan utilizando la mascarilla
en sus espacios se dice también adiós a
la mascarilla en las escuelas del estado
de nueva york eso afecta 2,7 millones de
estudiantes ahí todavía no están
incluidos el millón de estudiantes de la
ciudad de nueva york porque esta
decisión depende directamente del
alcalde eric adams y se espera que este
7 de marzo diga que ya no va a ser
necesario el uso de la mascarilla en las
escuelas tampoco será necesario que
presentemos nuestra cartilla de
vacunación no utilicemos la mascarilla
para acceder a bares o restaurantes
todo este despertar de nuevas
restricciones levantadas es porque la
situación pues poco a poco va mejorando
los contagios han caído un 98 por ciento
las hospitalizaciones cada vez son menos
y además en el estado de nueva york el
ritmo de vacunación es muy bueno aquí
hay casi un 76 por ciento de la
población que ha recibido la pauta
completa
y otra de las noticias en eeuu es que el
presidente joe biden anunció el programa
de street explíquenos en qué consiste
si se trata de un nuevo plan que ha
presentado la administración de bailén
para luchar contra la pandemia y que
tiene tres aspectos fundamentales uno
prepararse para futuras variantes 2
evitar otra vez el cierre de la economía
y 3 luchar contra la pandemia también en
el extranjero además va a ir en anuncios
también en su discurso de la unión esta
semana que va a facilitar masters
gratuitos a las casas de los
estadounidenses ya una primera ronda de
envíos se enviaron 270 millones de
pruebas gratuitas a las casas de los
ciudadanos de eeuu pues bien va a haber
otra ronda más y además se van a poder
hacer tres gratuitos en una farmacia y
serán positivos podrán acceder de manera
gratuita también a la píldora antiviral
de facer que la fed ya aprobó en
diciembre un plan muy ambicioso muy
ambicioso que pasa también por aprobar
un presupuesto de cerca de 30 mil
millones de dólares en el congreso así
que en eso está ahora eeuu en conseguir
vencer esta pandemia con estas nuevas
ideas sobre la mesa también miraremos
cómo avanza el programa gracias por la
información y gravemente les presentamos
otras noticias destacadas de las en
nuestro continente una píldora contra el
jove 19 fue aprobada por la organización
mundial de la salud se trata del mono
pira beer la primera pastilla que entró
en la lista de tratamientos recomendados
por la oms en el organismo sugiere que
este fármaco sólo lo uso en los
pacientes que no hayan desarrollado
síntomas graves previamente también les
cuento que el presidente brasileño ya ir
bolsonaro señaló que su gobierno estudia
la posibilidad de tratar el kobe 19 como
una endemia y es que brasil tiene un
promedio de 512 fallecidos por día a
causa del cob y lejos de los más de 3200
decesos diarios que se reportaron en el
récord de abril de 2021 sin embargo los
especialistas piden cautela y terminamos
este brevemente con una noticia positiva
la científica hondureña mariaelena botas
y fue nominada al nobel de paz por
desarrollar cover bucks ésta es una
vacuna de bajo costo contra el kobe 19
que está siendo distribuida en indian su
presión contribuye a cerrar las brechas
de x
y seguimos en centroamérica casi un
millón de estudiantes de panamá se
preparan para regresar a clases
presenciales esto es una buena noticia
especialmente para quienes no
continuaron sus estudios de manera
remota y es que unicef estima que en ese
país 2 de cada 10 alumnos no pudieron
acceder a la educación a distancia por
la falta de recursos veamos el informe
unos 950.000 estudiantes panameños
regresarán a las aulas el próximo 7 de
marzo dos años después de que cerraran
las escuelas en panamá por la pandemia
de kobe 19 entre sus más de 4 millones
de habitantes más de setecientos
cincuenta y siete mil personas han
contraído el virus y más de 8.100
personas han muerto a causa de este sin
embargo mantiene desde mediados de enero
pasado una tendencia descendente en
cuanto a la vacunación en el 84 6% de la
población neta es decir las personas de
5 años en adelante cuentan con una dosis
de la vacuna el 74,1 por ciento con 2 y
el 50,1 por ciento con dosis de refuerzo
que se aplica a mayores de 16 años en
medio de este panorama las autoridades
para acoger a los alumnos
esta madrugada continuamos con el
traslado de 89 docentes hacia zonas de
difícil acceso de la provincia de darién
y la comarca emberá wounan estos
educadores viajan vía terrestre 34 a
puerto kimba 23 a laja blanca 29 avisa y
3 de ellos a peñita
de acuerdo con un estudio realizado por
el banco mundial alrededor del 90% de
los estudiantes que han recibido
educación a distancia tienen
aprendizajes empobrecidos precisamente
una oficial de educación de unicef la
agencia de la onu para la infancia en
panamá explicó porque cuando analizamos
las cifras de manera más desagregada nos
damos cuenta que las familias en
situación de pobreza la mayoría accedió
a través de un celular y en muchos casos
este celular era compartido con 45
miembros de la familia la situación en
américa latina es crítica ya que sólo el
52% de la población tiene cobertura de
internet y sólo el 45 por ciento cuenta
con un computador por lo que según
unicef el 53 por ciento de los hogares
latinoamericanos señalan que la calidad
del aprendizaje de sus hijos no es la
adecuada
pasemos a chile allí ha aumentado el
número de pacientes graves y de muertes
ocasionadas por el cob y 19 incluso se
superó el pico de los más de 200
fallecimientos en un solo día una cifra
que no se veía desde junio de 2021 para
saber más de la pandemia en el país
austral vamos a santiago donde está
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna
patricia bienvenida en enero y en
febrero hubo un repunte precisamente por
omicron pero ahora la situación parece
estar cambiando cuáles son esas buenas
noticias
hola maría clara podríamos decir que
chile ya ha atravesado el peor momento
de la oleada de omicron en los últimos
siete días todas las regiones del país
registraron un descenso de los casos y
14 de las 16 regiones que existen en
chile lo hicieron en los últimos 14 días
es muy importante este hecho de que la
última semana los casos no hayan
aumentado y se encuentren un 33% por
debajo de lo que fue el tics de la
pandemia que se sitúa en este momento
entre el 14 y el 18 de febrero en el que
se llegaron a registrar cifras de hasta
38 mil casos de contagios diarios muy
lejos de los 23.000 reportados en las
últimas 24 horas el ministro de salud de
enrique parís valoro positivamente este
hecho el hecho de que los casos hayan
disminuido pero hay que señalar que
durante la omi crohn 8 regiones del país
registraron en enero y en febrero más
casos que en todo 2021 sin embargo esto
parece ir poco a poco descendiendo y la
preocupación por la pandemia también
deja de sentirse en las calles en chile
donde se vive en un ambiente de más
relajación
y en medio de ese ambiente de relajación
llegó una noticia y es que a partir de
marzo todos los colegios de chile deben
regresar a la presencialidad dentro de
las medidas es que el aforo debe ser del
100% cuéntenos cómo se está
implementando esto patricia
pues sin duda el retorno a clases ha
sido el gran batalla la gran batalla el
gran caballo de batalla entre el
gobierno y el colegio de profesores en
una pugna que continúa hasta el día de
hoy el pasado miércoles 2 de marzo el
propio presidente sebastián piñera
inauguraba el año escolar y marcaba que
este año la presencialidad va a ser
obligatoria en sus formas porque hasta
ahora desde el comienzo de la pandemia
en chile- ha prevalecido una modalidad
híbrida de clases presenciales junto a
clases online sin embargo el gobierno
insiste en la necesidad de que dos años
después del inicio de la pandemia los
alumnos vuelvan presencialmente a clase
por el efecto social que tiene en los
niños y también porque el hecho de que
se den clases online perjudica a
aquellos que están más desfavorecidos
socialmente y causa una ampliación de la
brecha social sin embargo el colegio de
profesores sigue insistiendo en que las
condiciones en chile- no están dadas y
que debería marcarse por ejemplo una
serie de aforos en las clases y sigue
prevaleciendo
por parte del colegio de profesores que
depende de la voluntad de los padres si
quieren acercar a sus hijos al colegio o
no esto es algo que deberá heredar el
próximo presidente electo gabriel boric
quien ya se ha manifestado de todas
formas a favor de la presencialidad y
del retorno normal a la normalidad de la
vuelta a clases algo que no ha ocurrido
en chile desde hace dos años
y otra noticia en el país es que se
cumplen dos años de la primera persona
contagiada con kobe 19 que se reportó el
3 de marzo del 2020 el gobierno hizo una
ceremonia cuéntenos qué pasó allí
el presidente sebastián piñera conmemoró
los dos años del inicio del primer caso
de la pandemia en chile el 3 de marzo
del 2020 con una ceremonia en la moneda
en la que se hundió homenaje a todas las
personas que han participado en la lucha
contra la pandemia personal de salud por
supuesto pero también recolectores de
basura y otro tipo de funcionarios
estuvieron presentes en esta ceremonia
que estuvo marcada también por el
lanzamiento de una botella de agua del
contenido de esta botella de agua al
presidente piñera le alcanzó por la
cabeza y también por los hombros se la
retiró y siguió el acto como si no
hubiera sucedido sin embargo ha habido
mucha polémica en el país por este hecho
era un acto de mucha seguridad y se ha
dicho que la persona que era una de las
nietas de un recolector de basura que se
encontraba allí siendo homenajeado por
el presidente no va a permanecer en
prisión por este hecho sin embargo hay
que resaltar algunas de las cifras que
ofreció el mandatario en esta ceremonia
de la moneda ya son más de 3.100.000 los
chilenos que se han contagiado el
presidente también lamentó el
fallecimiento de 42 mil personas a causa
del coronavirus 53 mil han pasado por la
uci se han realizado más de 30 millones
de pcr y en una población de 19 millones
de personas 18 millones de personas
señaló el presidente ya han recibido un
esquema completo de vacunación las
cifras hablan de que la población
objetivo un 93 por ciento de ésta ya ha
recibido un esquema completo de
vacunación se han aplicado en el país 13
millones de dosis de refuerzo y
1.400.000 de cuarta dosis en la que
chile lidera el ranking mundial los
países de la cabeza de américa latina
pero también se sitúa en la cabeza
mundial como uno de los primeros países
en aplicar esta cuarta dosis para
proteger a su población
gracias.patricia por esta información y
por las cifras de los contagios y la
vacunación en chile y ahora veamos cómo
ha avanzado precisamente la vacunación
en el continente concretamente miremos
las estadísticas de algunos países de
centroamérica
reportadas por our world in day está en
belice
de la mitad de la población ya tiene el
esquema completo y casi el 7 por ciento
tiene una única dosis en guatemala la
cifra de quienes ya están totalmente
vacunados es más baja del 31% mientras
que el 85 por ciento aún no completa los
biológicos en el salvador el
65,2 por ciento de los habitantes ya
tiene todas las dosis y el 4,8 por
ciento cuenta con el esquema marcial
y ahora nos vamos a bolivia porque en
estos dos años de pandemia varios de los
ciudadanos confiaron en las bondades de
las plantas y en la sabiduría de los
médicos ancestrales para tratar la
enfermedad del cob y 19 muchas de las
880 mil personas que contrajeron el
virus prefirieron tratarse con
infusiones e incluso el gobierno de
bolivia emitió un decreto en el que
incentiva estos conocimientos les
contamos más en este reporte
estas mujeres conocidas como chicleras
exhiben una variedad de plantas flores y
ungüentos naturales que son utilizados
para aliviar todo tipo de dolores e
incluso síntomas provocados por el cob y
19 para combatir los muchos bolivianos
han consumido a través de infusiones la
güira güira el eucalipto o el mãtico a
pesar de que estos saberes ancestrales
no cuentan con un sustento científico si
cuentan con el respaldo del gobierno el
gobierno democráticamente elegido del
presidente luís arce catacora
ha demostrado de que no se puede
gobernar sin escuchar al pueblo y el
pueblo
atesora el conocimiento de su medicina
tradicional en 2020 el gobierno
boliviano sacó un decreto que impulsa el
uso de estos saberes ancestrales y
publicó una guía para el abordaje de
estos conocimientos en el tratamiento
del cobi 19 tras reconocer en 2013 el
ejercicio de estos métodos bajo la ley
de medicina tradicional ancestral
boliviana gracias a los saberes
ancestrales las comunidades han
respondido hemos respondido desde
los conocimientos propios de nuestra
identidad cultural empleando sobre todas
las plantas medicinales aquí tenemos las
plantas plantas medicinales que los han
jurado a especialmente en la primera ola
de la pandemia cuando aún no habían
vacunas contra la enfermedad según la
directora de medicina tradicional del
ministerio de salud de bolivia hay al
menos 700 médicos tradicionales
matriculados sin embargo asegura que la
cifra es mayor y que están trabajando
para certificar los
en perú hay buenas noticias de la
pandemia pues los contagios y los
fallecimientos por kobe 19 continúan
bajando incluso el gobierno estima que
en marzo terminará el tercer pico de la
pandemia en el país andino conectamos a
esta hora con lima donde estaba nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías
francisco bienvenido y cuéntanos de qué
trata esta noticia y cuál es el panorama
de la pandemia en perú
hola maría clara las autoridades
peruanas anunciaron que la tercera ola
de la pandemia del joven 19 terminará en
este mes de marzo si los contagios y las
muertes continúan en descenso en todas
las regiones del país césar munayco
director ejecutivo de vigilancia de
salud pública ha dicho que los casos
confirmados por sars cap 2 están por
debajo de la cifra registrada en la
primera ola y ligeramente por encima del
nivel más bajo de la segunda ola en el
territorio peruano en lo referente a la
mortalidad el conteo se encuentra por
encima de la segunda ola pero debajo de
la primera el entusiasmo de las
autoridades locales también se
manifiesta por el descenso de la
hospitalización y por la ocupación de
las cámaras en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos que disminuyeron en 16%
llegando ahora a un 57% sin embargo el
ministerio de salud ha señalado que los
ciudadanos deberán seguir usando
mascarillas porque todavía existe una
amplia brecha en la aplicación de la
dosis de refuerzo de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19
francisco y el gobierno ya eliminó todas
las restricciones para los negocios
cuéntanos qué implica esto y cuáles son
las repercusiones en materia económica
ahora perú ya permite a foros al cien
por ciento en establecimientos se ha
establecido que los comercios deben
exigir a los ciudadanos portar el carnet
de vacunación que acredite el esquema
completo de inmunización y también
ordenar el uso de mascarillas esta
disposición gubernamental impulsará el
movimiento económico de consumo y
turismo por más de 300 millones de
dólares según cálculos oficiales sin
embargo existe un sector de
especialistas que se oponen a la norma
la califican de riesgosa porque no todos
los establecimientos cumplirían los
protocolos sanitarios en ese sentido el
ex ministro de salud óscar ugarte afirma
que desde el punto de vista sanitario la
norma es precipitada porque de acuerdo a
sus propias palabras implicaría el
riesgo de un repunte de la tercera ola o
en el peor de los casos de una cuarta
ola por su parte el sector empresarial
ve con entusiasmo esta apertura de
espacios comerciales porque considera
que impulsará la recuperación económica
del país y generará mayor empleo a los
peruanos
pero no todas las noticias son positivas
las clases presenciales se podrían
afectar por el retraso en la vacunación
de la población de quienes tienen entre
5 y 11 años cuéntanos cómo va la
aplicación de los biológicos en los
menores
las autoridades sanitarias han alertado
que sólo el 50 y 1.5 por ciento de la
población infantil en perú ha sido
inmunizada contra el cob y 19 solamente
se ha aplicado más de 2 millones de
dosis entre la primera y segunda dosis
la primera fue colocada casi 1.700.000
niños y la segunda alcanzó a tan sólo
700.000 menores esta situación causa
preocupación diversos especialistas
sostienen que el retraso de la
vacunación podría paralizar el inicio de
clases presenciales que se tiene
programado dentro de unos días y también
se revela que todavía el 60% de
profesores no cuentan con la tercera
dosis y aproximadamente 20.000 docentes
no tienen ninguna vacuna al respecto la
defensoría del pueblo advierte graves
falencias en la gestión del ministro de
salud hernán condori a quien señala de
no ser idóneo para ocupar el cargo
debido a que no habría priorizado la
vacunación en el perú estaremos
pendientes a ese inicio de clases como
va gracias francisco
ahora demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 destacadas en redes la agencia efe
dice que la deserción en las escuelas de
méxico fue de un promedio de 3% según un
estudio realizado por méxico evalúa y el
tecnológico de monterrey el nivel
preescolar fue el más afectado pues casi
el 9 por ciento de los estudiantes
dejaron de asistir a las aulas más de
450.000 dosis de la vacuna soberana 2
esa fue la donación que cuba le hizo al
sáhara occidental en el norte de áfrica
la embajada shahar drawing en la habana
afirmó que los biológicos serán
aplicados a los niños y a quienes estén
refugiados en campamentos las vacunas
desarrolladas en cuba todavía no tienen
el aval de la ms y terminamos con una
noticia publicada por ecuavisa pues los
jóvenes ecuatorianos entre los 12 y los
17 años ya pueden tener la dosis de
refuerzo contra el cob y 19 el biológico
que se pueden aplicar es el de facer
bayón tec y pueden ponerse los 6 meses
después de la más reciente dosis
y ese fue nuestro resumen semanal de lo
que pasa con la pandemia en américa
gracias por estar con nosotros y los
invitamos a que se conecten con france24
nos vemos
[Música]